hey what's going on it's Phil Burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday October 23rd 2017 what's
going on how yeah I am in Atlanta I am
back in Atlanta to continue on my acting
gig on a rainy day here Oh rainy days
and Monday's always can't be down who
the [ __ ] would write a song like that
you know it's like isn't the world
depressed enough rainy days and Monday's
always get you down how do you feel on
Tuesday when it's partly cloudy you're
miserable [ __ ] you playing music isn't
your job supposed to be to cheer people
up I should talk I mean one time Beck
put out an album and I guess it was
supposed to be like some thing when he
was going through a depression and then
he had a happier album and I bought them
one where he was more depressed and
remember my wife was like well what why
would you buy that one I don't know
because I'm gonna relate I don't [ __ ]
know anyway softback here in Atlanta
just landed in this [ __ ] rain and all
of this [ __ ] and you know we were up
there in the holding pattern and all
that it's gonna be a little 25 minutes
all that stuff people all huffing and
puffing and all I'm thinking is yeah
dude take another 55 minutes just don't
[ __ ] crash I don't care how long this
takes right so I get back to the hotel
everything goes great some others guy
[ __ ] lands it I don't know how they
do it it's [ __ ] amazing that they're
not freaking out is it just like I
couldn't see anything out my window and
I get back to the hotel room eyes God
[ __ ] I got to do the podcast let me
order a little bit of a room service so
I call up you know get a little grilled
cheese sandwich you know little turkey
BLT what do you get when he got on your
lunchtime menu and I call the guy up
right he's like hello room service and I
said yeah I'd like to order some food to
the Roman he goes oh I'm sorry we don't
have any broom City like I figure we
said it but he wouldn't like this happy
oh you know unfortunately we can't do
that right now oh I'm sorry that's what
he said oh I'm sorry we can't do that
right now oh yeah you don't sound sorry
you sound kind of chipper why don't you
have an why don't you have the proper
tone in your voice could you at least
pretend to sound a quarter as
disappointed as I am right now that I
have to do my [ __ ] podcast on an
empty stomach this podcast is kind of
suck right now because all I'm gonna be
thinking about is a grilled cheese
sandwich that I'm not eating all the Sun
just came out here comes the Sun
do-do-do-do
you know what's [ __ ] up George
Harrison wrote that and he's dead I bet
the rainy days and summer Monday's guy
is still alive you know why because God
doesn't want to hang out with them this
is the George Harrison here comes this
guy sounds alright I did a good job on
this one huh must not have been sleepy
and nodding off like when I made the
rainy days and Monday's [ __ ] Jesus I
hope it kills somebody so I have a
reason to setup down well wait I'm God I
can set him down there anyways you know
what [ __ ] cello
anyways plowing ahead here back in
Atlanta gonna knock got a couple more
days on this one I'm telling you man
it's really looking like a great one
film that I'm working on and then I go
back to go see my wife and my dog is
that my daughter in there I get to go
back hang out with them before the [ __ ]
am i doing this weekend oh my god we do
what I'm doing the first ever all things
comedy podcast network podcast festival
in Phoenix Arizona they say podcast
enough in that by the way I'm supposed
to mention that Bud Light will be the
official beer of the all things Comedy
Festival
alright we got a little bows in there
for Billy boos --less 67 days 67 days 67
days know boost will eat a some just
because I'm not drinking doesn't mean
you can't come to the all things comedy
festival in Phoenix Arizona
this Thursday Friday Saturday and listen
to some of the best podcasts and then in
the world in the universe I'm going to
go Donald Trump here while enjoying a
nice cold Bud Light there you go hey you
like that little [ __ ] commercial
there I'll be doing my podcast for the
first I don't know how I'm gonna do it
because I'm gonna do it just like I do
this well I just [ __ ] lay down on a
couch or a bed I feel at some point I do
have to address the crowd I think the
fact that I have no idea what the [ __ ]
is gonna happen like I don't know what
I'm supposed to do the crowd doesn't
know what they're supposed to do I think
something good is gonna happen that that
is my that is my prediction or something
bad well maybe it sucks but you know
what is the internet internet like
better than something that's amazing
something that sucks so no matter what I
feel like it's gonna be a win anyway 67
[ __ ] goddamn days no booze I feel
great
you know I look better I've lost weight
you know my livers happy share all of
those things but I got to tell you
something I really miss it I definitely
miss it you know did I had such a
[ __ ] amazing weekend played a Austin
City live the best sounding venue I've
ever [ __ ] been in the sound was was
in quite well they shoot Austin City
Limits there the sound was [ __ ]
incredible I worked with Dean Del Ray he
murdered all weekend I recorded when I
was there there was such pros they
handed it to me they had all three sets
are all of them already mixed and also
in what he guy said something about Pro
Tools like I could just hook it up into
Pro Tools and switch the mixing adjust
stuff if I wanted to
it was the most professional best
sounding coolest [ __ ] venue that I've
played in this in the States I think it
was unreal they had all these [ __ ]
photos from back in the day all the way
back to the first Willie Nelson was the
first guest that they had in 1974
believe this is their third venue but of
course they had the Stevie Ray Vaughan
one Neil Young just just everybody
everybody played there and so that was
incredible so anyways and then those
this place Lambert's barbeque right
around the corner which might have been
the best barbecue I have a gut just it's
not only the taste the quality of the
meat I went to the first time and I got
the pulled pork was [ __ ] incredible I
got to give these guys a shout out and
then I went back there again yesterday
and one of the people that worked at the
Austin City Live goes I used to work
there get the ribeye and and I got it it
was it was I forget what they I don't
know put it in coffee and something else
was the rub and it was [ __ ]
outstanding incredible food and all of
that [ __ ] so anyways so I went out there
I scheduled this weekend out there
around the Formula One race right that's
all I was gonna do I was gonna go there
play Austin City live and then go to the
f1 race and then that was it that was
gonna be my [ __ ] make-a-wish weekend
was gonna be perfect however I get there
and somebody tells me hey you know Jimmy
Vaughn is playing the [ __ ] was the name
of the venue we just went there
something sky something sky venue or
something this little bar cool ass
[ __ ] bar was like Jimmy Vaughn's
gonna be playing down there I only had
one show Saturday night you guys should
go down and check him out went down
checked him out set in a booth like five
feet away from the stage so the great
Jimmy Vaughn he had this unbelievable
[ __ ] keyboard player and drummer and
I just got to watch him play a set it
was this big CD album release party that
they were having we got to meet him in
between sets could not have been nice
nicer more generous just really warm
great guy and I gotta tell you about
this there was this one [ __ ] in the
crowd the more I go to like music shows
like they always talk about how
comedians get heckled like we get
heckled you know most times we deserve
it we say something that isn't funny or
we annoy somebody
right this guy's update he's he's
playing music and he's killing it and it
sounds great this [ __ ] in the crowd
he said something I want to [ __ ] hear
that [ __ ] I want to head loudly like
five feet away yelling at him like he
hired him for his private birthday party
and I don't know how I don't know how
Jimmy kept his composure I don't know
how he did like I couldn't believe in
smash the [ __ ] guitar over his head
he just was like nah man you know I'm up
here and playing music
this [ __ ] loser who's never done [ __ ]
with his life as far as I can tell he's
with some woman who literally falling
down drunk fell down drunk and he got
her another [ __ ] beer and they you
know other than that it was like there's
perfect evening and I just was as a
performer was astounded the the classy
way that he handled that guy cuz God
knows I wouldn't have but um other than
that [ __ ]
it was just this incredible night and me
and Dean were just sitting there like
you know a couple of kids could not
believe that we got to see him and got
to see him play like it was just classic
old-school musician you know we were out
in the in the [ __ ] parking lot he
just pulls up drove himself to the gig
you know just old school [ __ ] goes in
walks up on stage looked [ __ ] great
plugs in tunes up people he's tuning up
his own guitar you know all of that [ __ ]
people like sorry-looking none whatever
he's all tuned up walks off stage comes
back ten minutes later and just proceeds
to absolutely murder it for like 90
minutes right so like that wasn't great
enough I will go dude you believe we're
gonna seeing this guy and we're gonna go
to this race the next thing so anyways
we're with some of the people from
Austin City live Dan I go by the way I
go who's playing you your venue who
comes in their necks and they go Primus
I go when they go Sunday night I go get
the [ __ ] out of here I've never seen
them
all right Tim Alexander's one of my
favorite [ __ ] drummers of all time I
got to see this guy live so I changed my
[ __ ] flight and they go I'm an will
[ __ ] hook you up and we go to the
race I know this is probably annoying to
a lot of you guys that I got to do all
of this [ __ ] but I have to tell you what
am I gonna lie and act like I didn't
have a great wife supposed to tone down
my joy cuz you're in a goddamn cubicle
right now I'm sorry I'm sorry that I
[ __ ] humiliated myself for eight the
first eight years of my stand-up career
before I finally figured out how to be
funny and that I'm a 25 year overnight
success can I continue without pissing
off too many of you I know how the
[ __ ] I know how the Internet is I
know I works well [ __ ] you alright just
oh this if I ever get sick I don't need
to have a [ __ ] make-a-wish because I
already lived it this weekend
so we go to the goddamn race and we sit
we were sitting in turn 12 which was the
[ __ ] place to be you know the first
race I went to up in Montreal I was on
the start/finish line and it was great
to watch him go flying by 170 80 miles
an hour but you could barely see him you
want to be in the turns where they got a
they got to you know stomp on the brakes
and that's where the racing happens
that's where the passing happens dude we
were there we saw [ __ ] Lewis Hamilton
passed Matt max Verstappen the two best
drivers in the world on the two best
teams you know Mercedes in Ferrari right
in front of us and on that same [ __ ]
turn I think but botas past somebody we
got to see Hamilton past somebody else
after he had pitted and he had to try to
get back in the first place again we saw
him pass again and then on the final lap
we saw max Verstappen going around Kimi
räikkönen ready as they were
disappearing around the [ __ ] was at
12 13 14 15 I think 16 we could see 12
13 14 and 16 turns and then up the hill
you can see turn
and then over to the left you could see
like turn I don't know what it was five
or six it was ridiculous if you ever go
there you got to sit and turn 12 I'm
telling you or somewhere around there we
get to see all of like just get a map of
the of the of the track and from here on
out I don't give a [ __ ] what race I go
to I'm gonna look and see which which
turn has the sharpest [ __ ] turn after
a straightaway or whatever and that's
where I'm sitting because we actually
saw a little bit of an accident I
believe one of the the American teams
the Haas car got spun out that was right
in front of us and dude Dean Del Ray was
flipping the [ __ ] out like three times
during the race during those passes he
[ __ ] held up his forearm and he had
goose bumps
watching these guys slamming on the
brakes going around each other you know
he's a motorcycle [ __ ] car freak he
was losing his [ __ ] and he was he was so
going nuts I was like laughs and half of
the time you know you know when you
bring somebody to something and you want
it you want them to have a good time
you're so afraid like that they're gonna
look at you like you're any of this [ __ ]
dude I'm bored
you know they got anymore [ __ ] cheese
and crackers for me to eat he was losing
his mind freaking out so anyways as if
the race wasn't good enough max
Verstappen is right on Kimi räikkönen's
ass through 12 13 14 15 the whole time
and everybody is on their feet going
[ __ ] crazy and at the last second is
that going like up the hill he got
around him and everybody was going nuts
and he ends up coming in third place
he's on the podium everything is great
we get out of there
oh I forgot in the beginning of the race
when they did the whole Michael buffer
did all the announcements which some
some you know some racing fans didn't
like you know because they're all
[ __ ] snobby and [ __ ] I saw a couple
American fans apologizing it [ __ ] you
this is America alright we overeat and
we're loud alright if you don't like it
don't have a [ __ ] race here you
[ __ ] Jesus Christ do you get all
upset when the [ __ ] Italians cry every
time a Ferraris in first place for a lap
[ __ ] stuck-up [ __ ] anyways and they
actually when they brought out Daniel
Ricciardo they actually [ __ ] is this on
right now alright sorry little technical
technical difficulty there when they
brought him out will Buxton had wrote
written all the the intros and when they
brought out Daniel Ricciardo they
[ __ ] the day and Michael buffer say
Rikki Rockett remember when I couldn't
remember the guys names and I was saying
Rican Rikki Rican burg and all of that
[ __ ] cuz I you know so new to the sport
one time I called Daniel Ricciardo Rikki
Rockett obviously knowing that that was
the drummer from poison so he actually
said that [ __ ] nuts is that so
anyways at some point I got to get a
picture with Rikki Rockett and Daniel
Ricciardo see if that ever [ __ ]
happens who knows who knows maybe Rikki
Rockett cures his shadow next thing you
know he gets into the race he goes to
[ __ ] Austin he's also sitting in turn
but Daniel Ricciardo be like you know
what it'll be Grayson at that point it's
never gonna [ __ ] happen whatever so
anyways this morning I wake up and I'm
looking at the final you know results
and everything to see who won what and I
noticed that all of a sudden max
Verstappen is down in 4th place and
there's all this whole [ __ ] Days of
Thunder Ricky Bobby [ __ ] controversy
I guess he [ __ ] went off on this I
guess is this racing steward who [ __ ]
him over in Japan Mexico and now in
Austin and he was so mad he said he
hoped that the fans don't show up in
Austin next year it's just like dude
dude he's kind of [ __ ] you around the
globe there's no reason to single us out
right did you not like your nickname and
the [ __ ] intros sorry um but anyway
so it was a phenomenal race I'm actually
blowing through so much of this [ __ ] I
should probably try and slow down here
but I have to get to the next thing so
then we left there and then we went out
my wife better not listen to this
podcast she's gonna get annoyed with me
then we went back to the hotel dropped
off our [ __ ] and we went back down over
to the venue and we got to see
we got to see Primus and they basically
opened for themselves played like for an
hour and then took a half hour break and
played for another 90 minutes and I
gotta be honest with you I am NOT a drug
guy but I actually with all the video
[ __ ] that they had going on and the host
psychedelic vibe oh by the way another
heckler at that show like Larry's one of
his petals if something wasn't working
you know so less is talking to the crowd
I'm talking about he's actually talking
about that was that booth you know those
damn blue-collar tweakers never right
there that's how old town I yeah that's
[ __ ] song he was talking about how he
came up with that twinkers I thought he
was talking about meth you know I didn't
know it was about the waters being
stolen from Northern California so he's
sitting there talking about it cuz
they're trying to fix
Larry's pedals this guy in the crowd
goes started [ __ ] preaching like Ike
was beside myself I would think
everybody in the crowd would just beat
the [ __ ] out of me but less once again
did both of them just handled it like a
pro he joked his way out of it he said
something [ __ ] hilarious about a you
know presenting any questions he had
please present them in written form true
or false questions work best for me I'm
butchering it but it was like really
funny to the point I was actually kind
of happy the guy heckled him because you
know les is [ __ ] hilarious so I
finally got to see Tim Alexander play
live his [ __ ] kit is it's [ __ ] it
he has like a double bass pedal on like
a 20-inch bass drum and they had all of
this stuff going on in the background
and I'm sitting there you know trying to
figure out you know what Tim is playing
and all of that [ __ ] and after they
opened for themselves they took a half
hour break then they came out and they
started playing all the stuff off to
their new album I hope I say this right
desaturating seven
and they had all this video stuff going
on and I actually looked over at Dean at
one point I believe when they had
elephants jumping on trampolines and and
the way that the filter was on it it
looked like was that really cool movie
Finn Vin Diesel did where he couldn't
see just how you would look I keep
thinking riddick bowe I know it's not
that that was a boxer I forget what the
I can never remember the name of the
movie but it was like sort of in that
sort of filter and it was an elephant
jumping up and down on a trampoline and
then it became three and then one of
them started doing somersaults and what
I love when it came down like the trunk
would like would be like fluttering in
the wind as it came down and I literally
looked over at Dean I go you know what
I've never had this thought before but I
really wish I was on drugs right now I'm
not a drug guy you know all right stayed
away from you know I smoke weed every
once in a while usually when I'm not
drinking because I'm so [ __ ] bored
I don't know how straightedge people do
it I really don't but I pretty much
stayed away from all of like the evil
drugs other than alcohol
I think alcohol is an evil drug it's an
angry drug like you know I mean like
weed is cool mushrooms are cool but like
coke is evil alcohols evil I don't know
I feel like the [ __ ] that just makes you
kind of sit around you can't really do
anything just giggling it yourself you
know I don't know why anybody would like
just choose to stay in the dark so I
don't know maybe just a [ __ ] dark
human being and you're relate to it but
you'd think you'd want to go the
opposite way I don't [ __ ] know but
I've never taken mushrooms or anything
like that but uh I don't know that was
the first time I was just like you know
I wouldn't might would have I wouldn't
have minded being in like an altered
state throughout this if I could have
just give him ice I just I would worry
that I would I would freak out
that's why I never you know with like my
generation always they were always like
you know they had they'll think telling
you stories about people took LSD and
they pulled their eyeballs out and
[ __ ] jump I mean I would never [ __ ]
with LSD either but like I don't know it
was actually going like you know I think
this would have been one of those times
I mean if I just did mushrooms once
every 49 years I mean it's like be like
Halley's Comet you know sort of frame I
don't [ __ ] know all I know was they
were unbelievable and I can't even I
don't know which was my favorite I think
it was southbound pachyderm it's
probably my favorite it was just an
unbelievable the whole night was just
[ __ ] incredible and that was my
weekend I got to do three shows at
Austin City live the best venue as far
as sound I've ever performed it I then
got to see Jimmie Vaughan in this small
little bar like doing the world a favor
he doesn't need to do that gig comes
down right and then I got this little f1
race and then I saw Primus after that
[Laughter]
and I come back to Atlanta to do a
[ __ ] movie to pretend to be somebody
else I swear to God there's a piano
waiting to fall on my [ __ ] head at
some point during this week something's
gonna happen and actually I already did
but am I gonna talk to you about it was
some other [ __ ] [ __ ] getting some
work done on the house and the workers
came there and somebody said hey the
door to your house was open and I was
like oh [ __ ] did somebody break into our
house so I'm dealing with that but you
know what that's what happens that is
what happens when you have all this good
stuff going on something something
happens you stop you [ __ ] toe son you
get audited something's gonna happen I
don't [ __ ] though
so anyways doing all of this [ __ ] I
missed pretty much all of the football
and all of that crap for this weekend I
do know that the Patriots beat the
Falcons
so that's cool for and - do we actually
have a strong division bills of foreign
to Patriots of foreign - dolphins of
foreign - Jets are what are they they
three and what would that be they played
six games three and three I don't know
what I don't know what they are well
they might be three and five because I
think we might have had a bye week I
don't know what but AFC East after all
these years of being so [ __ ] weak is
actually a really competitive division
this shift so that's pretty exciting and
I watched what did I watch my apologies
by the way my apologies to the [ __ ]
Houston Astros I love you uniforms
I just haven't watched baseball in so
long I thought they still had those
shitty once that Jeff Bagwell had to
wear
you [ __ ] uniforms are great and I
gotta give a shout-out to Sports
Illustrated some guy I was watching this
pregame because I watched Game six and
seven you know when I was waiting to go
on and I thought I was convinced CC
Sabathia Game seven I thought the
Yankees were gonna have that one but
anyways they were talking about before
like Game seven that's some good I don't
know who wrote it in Sports Illustrated
in 2014 the Year the Astros went 70 and
92 he put him on the cover of Sports
Illustrated and said you know please
welcome your 2017 World Series champions
he said that in 2014 when they was
seventy and ninety two are in the midst
of being that he or she said that right
and that they come back from the story
and the guy host in the sports program
go that was a pretty good prediction
it's like pretty good that is [ __ ]
unbelievable
like anybody right now could look at the
Yankees and go like eh yeah I think
they're gonna win it next year that when
it the year after or sometime within the
next three years that is not a big
prediction all right they got all this
young talent that they're [ __ ] playing
great they way overachieved
as far as what the organization thought
they were gonna do this year they came
one game away from the World Series
anybody can say that these guys gonna
win another one you know that's what I
think I think they're gonna win another
one here in the next few years but
[ __ ] look at the Astros who've never
[ __ ] won in 2014 and then pick the
year I think in the next three years
blah blah daddy that would have been
great but to actually nail the year I
mean they haven't won it yet but guy
goes way I was a pretty good prediction
I don't know if that the guy was a
little jealous my nuts
I'm trying not to talk all sports cuz I
know people are [ __ ] getting nuts with
that sometime so let me [ __ ] go uh
first of all I'm really cursing a lot I
don't know why probably cuz I was on a
plane today and I always suck wood after
I've been on a plane but uh let's get
back to drugs and booze alright this is
what I realized I like I like getting
[ __ ] up I do I really enjoy it I like
it hammered or [ __ ] you know every
once in a while smoking some weed I do
and I'm not an addictive personality as
the cops show up to see what's under my
bed right now I hope you that's good to
hear the siren in the background I hope
you didn't think I was alluding to the
fact that I killed a hooker or something
that was I was talking about drugs a
siren went by sometimes this [ __ ]
thing doesn't pick it up anyways so like
now I have a drank but done anything for
like 67 days and I could go for the rest
of my life I could do it but it's just
it's so it's like really I don't know
it's boring I don't know how like I have
to commend everybody who gets into a
program and just [ __ ] does that I
don't know how you do it but it's it's
it's amazing and I feel like in a way by
me saying how [ __ ] boring it is I'm
actually [ __ ] with you sobriety so I
apologize but if you guys been watching
Bert Kreischer by the way going sober
for October and I believe Tom Segura
they always do like those battles like
losing weight and being sober and all
that [ __ ] and I think Joe Rogan is doing
it too
so all I know about from the what I know
about the three of them November better
get in the fetal position because I have
a feeling they're gonna come back strong
I know I am I think I am I don't know I
don't know I like losing the weight and
that type of [ __ ] but uh I I think I'm
gonna be I want I would like to be more
of someone who who picks his battles
when I drink you know like I got to tell
you Austin is a hard place not to be
drinking like we went to go see Jimmy
Vaughn like we was sitting at this table
with some other people that knew Jimmy
and they were the nicest people ever and
a couple of them that were at the table
were [ __ ] just doing shots and I
swear to God they did like three shots
in an hour and these people could drink
because they were just totally like fine
and I would be lying to you if I wasn't
looking at them drinking going god
dammit I would kill from one of those
right now and I was trying to
rationalize it like what if I just did
one and this is the weird thing about me
if I'm a habbit guy so I know I'm not
like a chemical person I don't think so
but if I just do that one how I work is
I immediately have to order a water
after that and let the buzz start to
fade alright because if I don't then I'm
gonna get another then I'm gonna gonna
get another but I I got this weird thing
with the water it [ __ ] it's almost
like I threw at my face and I wake up
going like alright dude settle down
settle down but if I don't do that
I definitely put a dent in a bottle but
uh I don't know last night man at that
Primus show I'm not blaming Primus here
when I [ __ ] go off the wagon but I
was just like you know what
am I gonna try mushrooms the [ __ ] is who
tries mushroom so the first time is 49
just had a kid I can't have that on my
resume right plus I also think the first
time you do them you should probably be
in your house where you feel safe but I
can't do that now cuz I'm a dad and I
don't think it would be smart to do it
at a concert well I want you to [ __ ]
elephant doing somersaults on a
trampoline I don't know I'm just
throwing this [ __ ] out here if anybody
has any suggestions how to walk that
line anyways now that I've talked about
recreational drugs here now those
recreational I don't know what I don't
know what I just always hear that word
on the [ __ ] news
let me promote the all things Comedy
Festival this is the podcast read okay
we're having our first all things Comedy
Festival at the end of this month
October 26 27 28 and 29 oh I'm sorry so
that goes right through Sunday in
Phoenix Arizona
alright 26 27 28 29 Stars a Friday
Saturday Sunday I'm gonna be there
recording my first ever live Monday
morning podcast all right Doug Stanhope
the great Doug Stanhope the legend is
doing his podcast at the Orpheum Theatre
Bert Kreischer sober Bert Ari Shaffir I
think he also might be sober
the crab feasts are also on the line up
we're taking over downtown Phoenix with
a pop up podcast studio and the whole
network is going to be there if you're
in the Phoenix area come hang with us go
to the all things go to all things
comedy calm to get your tickets yeah I
don't know what time I'm coming in cuz
I'm coming in from Atlanta actually I'm
going out to LA see my wife and kid then
I'm gonna fly in the day of and I'm
gonna be walking around [ __ ] taking
pictures and thanking everybody for
coming out so if you guys bought tickets
that came out I really really appreciate
it
alright let's get to some of the more of
the podcast Reed's here oh look who's
here up everybody it's one of our
favorite [ __ ] reads on the podcast
it's old zip are you hiring well are you
do you know where to post your job to
find the best candidates zip recruiter
is different with zip dot-com you can
post your job to over 100 job sites over
100 of the web's leading job board sorry
with one click so you can just rest easy
knowing your job is going to be seen by
the right candidates then zip puts it
smart matching technology to work
actively notifying qualified candidates
about your job with within minutes of
posting so you can receive the best
possible matches
gotta get classes you can even get a
head start on the interview process by
adding screening questions to your job
post what to your job posts to help
identify the most qualified candidates
ever read a sentencing you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about
that was one of them so you don't have
to waste time sorting through the stack
of resumes to find the perfect fit and
the easy to use zip dashboard lets you
manage your hiring process from start to
finish all in one place find out today
why is it
has been used by growing businesses of
all sizes and industries to find the
most qualified job candidates with
immediate results right now my listeners
can't post jobs on zip REE
gluten for free that zip recruit comps
iceberg one more time huh
zip recruiter comp cyber all right
simply they getting traditional home
security can be a punishing and
expensive task simply safe home security
is a better way to protect your home
simply safe got rid of everything that
makes home security a hassle man they
make it easy for you the system is easy
to use and completely wireless you can
install it yourself
that's great you can do it yourself in
under an hour simply safe has no long
term contract
there's no obligations hey honey we had
a great night leave it alone I don't
want a relationship this is an
award-winning home security technology
with tech magazine seen it calls simply
safe better smarter home security your
home is protected around-the-clock with
24/7 professional monitoring if there's
trouble they'll send police by the way
when I said my door was on my wife and
kid weren't home ok by the way just to
let you know in case you were concerned
this service cost just fifteen dollars a
month with simply fake that's three
times less than what the other guys
charged and simply safe has no hidden
fees protect your home today you can by
simply faith at your local Best Buy and
have your home protected by tonight or
simply safe bird calm for a special 10%
off that simply safe bird calm for 10%
off your home security system simply
faith beurre combi you are our two more
everybody hang in there movement watches
everybody movement watches pronounced
movement MV MT that's how they spell it
was founded on the belief that style
shouldn't break the bank the watchmakers
goal is to change the way consumers
think about fashion by offering high
quality minimalist products at
revolutionary prices the company started
by two Broke college kids that wanted to
wear stylist watches but couldn't afford
them I never understood this they're
broke and they started a watch company
how do you do that so they started their
own watch company alright how is this
like just how you started
well I was a I wasn't broke I was living
at home with my parents and I worked in
a dental office I paid off my [ __ ]
truck and when it died I put a new
engine in it rather than buying a new
car and then I paid off the [ __ ]
engine then I finally started making
money off of my stand-up gigs and I
started banking that I paid off my
student loans and then I had an
electrical fire my truck burned down on
the side off of Route 24 and then I said
well [ __ ] I'm moving in New York
anyways and I don't need a car so I
moved down there and I thought well I
got to get a day job and I got a couple
of gigs and then my mindset went from
you know I got to get a day job to I got
to get more gigs I took buses and trains
[ __ ] like that
it sucked in that I don't know
eventually I started making money 20
years later did you guys really want me
to take that big of a left turn during
you read cuz you could tell me to talk
about it I will uh it's a classic design
quality construction style minimalism
over 100 million watches sold in 160
countries then I was in Li Massachusetts
and somebody threw a [ __ ] dinner roll
at me and it missed and they threw it so
hard when it hit the back wall that
actually scared me and this is thing it
was a fresh roll - he threw it so hard
it sounded like it sounded like a stale
roll movement watched his start at just
$95 one time somebody threw dental floss
at me when I was on stage because I was
talking about working in a dental office
at a department store you're looking at
four to five hundred bucks get 15% off
today with free shipping and free
returns by going to move an ice to work
for free and then I moved out to Oregon
for gas money by going to movement calm
/ / this watch has a really clean design
that makes a great fashion statement now
is the time to step up your watch can go
to movement watches comm / / join the
movement by the way Tim Alexander's
[ __ ] drum kit was one of the coolest
things I've ever seen
he has like he has like three rack toms
and then mixed in with the rack toms on
like a rack above it he has like these
octobots like three different octa bonds
the
he has like these like splash cymbals on
one side he's got like the rack dude I'm
a drum geek so I was videoing the drum
kit watching all of this stuff do one of
the most fluid [ __ ] players do you
know he was the player that actually got
me out of my john bond initially got me
out of the john bonham like death spiral
and I was like I had all I'm doing is
listening to John Bonham this isn't good
I'm never gonna sound like I'm never
gonna play like him I need to listen to
other people and the double bass guys so
many of them like what they were playing
I just couldn't hear a groove and then
he came along and the way he applies the
double bass when he puts it in and what
I love about he's playing is how fluid
it is in the space that he has and just
grooves his his ass off I can't believe
I finally got this on song got to see
him it was just amazing anyways
stamps.com everybody oh the old
favorites stamp saves you time and money
which you can use to grow your business
and can mail I can mail any letters any
packages using just my computer and
printer and the mailman picks it up
avoid the hassle man of going to the
post office and mail everything from
postcards to envelopes to packages
domestic or international create your
stamps account in minutes with no
equipment to lease and no long term
commitments click print mail shoot [ __ ]
and you're done unlike the post office
stamps com never closes print postage
for letters or packages at your
convenience
24/7 keyword descriptors convenient easy
reliable flexible like the [ __ ] up the
street I use stamps com any time I send
out my posters I'm gonna [ __ ] myself
out signing them afterwards like the
poster that will be available this
weekend for the first ever live Monday
morning podcast go to stamps com click
on the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in bird that stamps
comm enter bird stamps com never go to
the post office again alright where are
we here let's get to some of the
questions here for this week
oh you're not gonna believe this I
accidentally hit stop so then I had to
press record again and somehow I hit
stop again without realizing it I just
talked for 45 minutes then nobody heard
alright let me start this over again
with your questions here alright I'll
try to act like I'm still excited that
I'm not [ __ ] starving do you hear
that that's my stomach growling
alright Robert Plant everybody Oh
freckles just want to let you know
Robert Plant was interviewed on the
Howard Stern Show on Tuesday he goes
through his whole career and up to the
present because he has a new album
coming out incredible interview thought
you might enjoy it thank you and go [ __ ]
yourself I absolutely I have to hear
this [ __ ] interview the problem is is
I only have Sirius satellite radio in my
car my cars in Los Angeles I'm in
Atlanta Howard Stern fans please send me
a link let me know where I can see it
watch it whatever the [ __ ] goes on
however you kids do it because I'm not
gonna be able to figure it out I have to
listen to it I have to listen to him go
through the whole thing banned to joy
into Zeppelin John Bonham dying coming
back within the mood and then what else
did he do honey drippers the whole
[ __ ] thing I I can't wait to listen
you know when I was at the Austin City
Live they had an incredible picture of
him too you know he's another guy you
know just age naturally now look at him
he looks [ __ ] badass all the wrinkles
on his his face he just looks like he
looks [ __ ] amazing I don't know why
people would choose Botox and all of
that [ __ ] oh he's a great one 38 year
old bus driver makes college hoops team
Billy girl did you see these this
article on barstool sounds like someone
you would commend on a job well done
you're always telling people it's never
too late on the flip side what are the
negatives here does anyone lose out hey
man if you can't beat out a six-foot
eight 380 pound [ __ ] 38 year old guy
it's on barstool sports which by the way
is you know that's got to be the best
combination of being hilarious and then
also
you know what's going on in sports how
let's see you this guy 38 years olds
gonna be 39 in November he's 6 feet 8
and weighed 380 pounds he's 38 waist 380
you know it's funny to get 380 pounds
all you have to do is just gain at 38
years of age all you have to do is just
gain 10 pounds a year you know for the
first like I don't know how many years
people like oh my god the kids emaciated
then all of a sudden right yeah 9 years
old you're 90 pounds like what the [ __ ]
10 year 120 to 200 and that's you know
380 he just kept getting Balak giantism
buddy just keep eating you're asking me
what is the downsize the downside sorry
downsize well slip there
what is it downside maybe is uh blowing
out his Achilles I mean I don't feel bad
somebody can't beat out of [ __ ]
soon-to-be 39 year old 380 pound 6 foot
8 guy you know what that division
whatever division that is that's amazing
good for him man good for him you know
what it is he said his basketball dream
died and he's 38 years old gonna be 39
he has two teenage kids it's like this
we get dreamed I'd [ __ ] had the kids
man and you're a good dad I bet you see
just like I got a take whatever job I
can get all right the fall guy no sorry
brain activity after death oh my god I
can't believe I already did this I
talked I just I hope I can do this
justice again brain activity after death
all right let's let's reminisce about
this one because I've already read it
before all right
when I first recorded this but didn't
realize I wasn't recording let me check
again to make sure this [ __ ] thing is
on that freaked me out
brain activity after death and I was
just like because in my will I'm gonna
get cremated so I'm like you know even
still if you have brain activity after
death I'd rather just get thrown in an
oven to just finish off the rest of me
like ah it's over real quick as opposed
to laying in a coffin feeling worms
going into my ears dear Billy Ripper
this are
absolutely [ __ ] me up not only is death
gonna suck but also I feel the need to
know I feel the need now to make sure
people don't talk [ __ ] about me as I'm
dying or here let's get a pizza as I'm
Bari to check out for good
alright this freaks me out here alright
scientists say your brain still works
after death and you know when you're
dead now I saw a thing a long time ago
where this scientist was on TV with this
religious guy who was talking about
people who died and then came back to
life and then they talked about what
they saw and what they heard and all
that and it was all this fascinating
stuff about watching people working on
them and floating above the table and
all of this type of [ __ ] and then the
scientist guy just killed all of it by
going like nothing has ever been dead
and has been brought back to life what
you're talking about here is people
having a near-death experience just
because your heart stops it doesn't mean
you're dead your brain is still working
you can still in he basically was saying
your if your eyes are open you know you
can still see some [ __ ] we're not sure
how much you're still alive
it's not until your brain has no
functioning that's the final the final
part of it I remember reading when I
read that book a perfect storm they went
through all of drowning and now your
brain sitting there firing all that that
last bit of life all this brain
activity's going trying to get your
heart going and just doesn't happen and
then that's it from the lack of oxygen
then your brain dies last and then
that's it but you don't like [ __ ]
live I mean not dead you're not dead yet
right anyway scientists may be inching
closer to answering one of the greatest
mysteries of life what happens after you
die according what happens under your
doing don't you hate those [ __ ] web
sites will you skip past the advertising
and you scroll down and then they show
it to you anyways [ __ ] annoying
according to researchers in New York a
person's brain is still active after
death meaning in many cases they can be
aware that they've passed away a team
from New York University Lane gone
School of Medicine has been studying
patients who suffered cardiac arrests or
a heart attack which stops their heart
for a period of time quote technically
speaking that's how you get the time of
death it's all based on the moment when
the heart stops yeah but you're not dead
you're not dead your heart just stopped
that's why they can bring you back to
life because you're still alive they
just get the [ __ ] thing going again I
learned all of this from one scientist
they'll describe watching doctors and
nurses working they'll describe having
awareness of full conversations of
visibility yeah but you your ears didn't
die if you scream in an ear it's still
gonna [ __ ] vibrate because it's still
alive it's still working the heart
stopped anyways they knew all this [ __ ]
that they ever though eyes wouldn't know
what was going on according to par Nia
these recollections was then verified by
the medical staff yeah this is all
stupid yeah just because you're not dead
yet sir you're not dead all right so
just [ __ ] let go of that I think you
know what I think happens when you die
I think it's a beautiful experience I
think it's what my idea of what [ __ ]
mushrooms at a Primus concert is like I
think he's laying there I think you
totally relaxed you let go all of the
[ __ ]
and you'll if you're lucky enough after
your heart stopped to kind of be aware
of a little to be aware that you're
dying I think it would be very humble
experience and I would give thanks for
the amazing life that I had and if there
was nothing after it I would I would be
good with it
I would be fine with going into the
ground and enriching the soil with my
carcass I don't need to go anywhere
after this I went to [ __ ] I performed
at Austin City live I then saw Jimmie
Vaughan I then went to an f1 race and
then saw Primus I need to go to heaven
after that [ __ ] you're talking about
yeah I don't think it's this big
fearful thing I don't think it is I
think it's somebody torches you to depth
the tortures bed that's the bad thing
how you die is bad but I don't think the
death that being dead is bad I think I
think it'll be [ __ ] amazing I think
it's gonna be amazing
why would you think anything else you
can't stop it might as well look at it
in a positive way remember when uh who
was that guy Lou Jesus Christ he's only
a legend he was in that band that sang
about [ __ ] heroin Lou Reed
I remember they said when he died this
woman said she was looking at him and he
had the most like amazed and like
inquisitive look on his face like he was
totally enjoying it and just taking in
the [ __ ] experience that's how you
want to go out you know how I got I'm
sorry oh god yeah doing all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that don't fight it just give in to
it
what are you special you're gonna keep
[ __ ] living like a vampire the fall
guy dear bill big red balls of fire
I don't have a question more of an
observation on Harvey Weinstein the
Harvey Weinstein situation Harvey
Weinstein is banned from the Oscars a
little elite club it's not a little Club
it's a [ __ ] it is a very elite club
and I could tell by I already said this
[ __ ] before I knew this guy has issues
with Hollywood I believe you know my
saying little elite club the same club
that Roman Polanski a pedophile who pled
guilty he did not plead guilty to being
a pedophile he what he pled guilty to
was improper behavior that's what he was
willing to plead guilty to and then he
ran and get the [ __ ] out of the country
because that's what innocent people do
although if I was brought up on those
charges in another country I probably
would have got the [ __ ] out of it too
however I would never be in a hot tub
with a [ __ ] 13 year old girl giving
her booze or whatever the [ __ ] was going
on
and Bryan Singer who's been accused of
molesting underage child stars and
feeding them drugs are a part of the big
Hollywood elite club that these sick
bastards want us to believe is honorable
I don't know if anybody ever said it was
honorable you said on your previous
podcast that this was one of the mo I
guess a they try this is for film and
honoring felt maybe they do I don't pay
attention this [ __ ] i watch sports you
said in your previous podcast that this
was one of the most disgusting god-awful
situations you ever heard of the
Weinstein thing yeah Weinstein [ __ ] up
sure but so far none of his accusers
were underaged
I swear to god I know what you guys are
thinking you're thinking what I thought
the first time I read this this guy's
not gonna downplay what Weinstein did
hey you know he [ __ ] up allegedly did
I guess I should still be saying alleged
what are you leged lead and a guide [ __ ]
them a lot of them were aspiring stars
who were willing to do anything for fame
objection speculation dude you're just
creating this [ __ ] argument because
you have issues with Hollywood and their
careers failed and now they're bitter so
they did yeah okay all right this you
sound like the defense attorney for
Harvey Weinstein right now but no one
all in capital capitals mentions two
pedophile pedophile cases involving
other tinsel moguls because it would
completely ruin the industry that's not
true it's been mentioned people have
said stuff like that they don't have
evidence to bring charges okay this is
what happens it's the same reason why
however uyc probably won't go to jail
like the level of [ __ ] evidence that
you need in order to bring charges okay
it's a difficult [ __ ] thing when
you're dealing with people with that
level of power trying to catch them in
the act you know how long do they know
that these Mafia dons are doing what
they're doing how often do they know
that these [ __ ] oil companies and
insurance companies and all of these
people Catholic Church and all these
people do they have money they got money
dude okay
so I don't know why you're just singling
out Hollywood what are you Fox News you
know or CNN when they just single out
[ __ ] Trump for grabbing [ __ ] I
don't understand you forgot if you got a
[ __ ] lay waste you got to go straight
across the board here anyways it's made
this but okay watch this documentary if
you can find it called an open secret
all right well meaning what that I'm out
in Hollywood I don't know that this
shit's going on I guess in me it's an
open secret with the people that know
those people this is a classic [ __ ]
guy who watches a goddamn documentary
he's not a [ __ ] lawyer he doesn't
even know how to present his [ __ ]
argument it's all speculation that are
willing to do anything for fame like
where did you get that you just pulled
that out of the at you're asked to
support your [ __ ] argument here I'm
not saying this [ __ ] isn't going on but
like you know there's all kinds of
people that fly over to these third
world countries evidently and are doing
god-knows-what with underaged [ __ ] kids
so I don't know why you're just singling
this out I mean if you're gonna attack
this shouldn't you be against it
straight across the [ __ ] board or
maybe you're just saying this because
the Weinstein thing came about I don't
know what you're doing it's the fact
that you're downplaying what Harvey
Weinstein allegedly did that's what's
weirded me out here anyways that
documentary an open secret it's made by
the same director who may deliver us
from evil which is about the pedophilia
in the Catholic Church
well this director is either fighting
the good fight or picking low-hanging
fruit here that movie was released in
theaters and got that for the most part
major distribution from film companies
but an open secret hasn't had a wide
release in his two years that is
premiered yeah why do you think why do
you think why don't you make a [ __ ]
documentary about well how [ __ ] up the
oil oil industry is and try to get the
oil industry to put it out they're not
gonna they're not gonna shoot themselves
in the foot because at the
they money wins all right same way why
the NFL acted like they didn't see that
Ray Rice [ __ ] thing it's still
unknown by a majority of the populace
Weinstein is taking the shitstorm
well the real monsters are saying phew
good thing we're not in the forefront
it's [ __ ] okay I can't understand if
you're saying Weinstein shouldn't be he
should be taking a [ __ ] storm but not
the whole [ __ ] storm I think that's what
you're trying to say here Corey Feldman
and Elijah Wood mentioned pedophilia is
running rampant in Hollywood but no one
gives that issue the time of day I would
actually argue that they're trying to
investigate it but people have such high
levels of power because what I've
learned from the Harvey Weinstein thing
when I listen to that disgusting tape of
him saying I'm used to this knowing that
that tape wasn't enough to arrest him is
I mean you're borderline have to catch
somebody in the act when they have that
level of money because then it becomes
your word against their word and then
they have money to tie it up forever in
court it's terrible
anyways RB ism is equivalent to a nerd
whose depth desperate to get laid all
right dude I'm done with this [ __ ]
thing I'm done with this thing you know
what's funny sir in all of this you're
going after these so you feel that
pedophiles should be punished I agree
but you feel that creeps like Harvey
Weinstein are just are the equivalent to
a nerd who's desperate to get laid
that's how you view alleged rape I mean
I don't I don't know I don't know where
you're going with that sir but uh
you know you wrote a lot of words
all right milf question hey Bill you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
all right guilty as charged
you know what the guy who wrote that
Harvey Weinstein I think we was sitting
down sometimes people writing isn't
there the best way for them to
communicate maybe if we sat down and we
actually talked I can understand what
the [ __ ] he was saying all right milf
question hey Bill you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I love your podcast and all your
stand-ups emphasis for family is [ __ ]
great - thank you anyways I need some
advice out 24 and I work at a bar as a
sound guy until I graduate which is this
December anyways last week a beautiful
redheaded woman who's above 40 starts to
hit on me I give her my number and
lately I've been texting her banging a
MILF is Bill always been on my bucket
list I just that's just [ __ ] gross to
me I don't know why I just think that's
[ __ ] gross why you have to bring up
the fact that she's a mother and has a
kid and you want to [ __ ] her is just
weird why can't you just say she's hot
however this woman is starting to seem
like she wants more than just a night or
two of [ __ ] she has a kid which I
don't [ __ ] want to deal with
whatsoever so here's my question how do
I deal with this you [ __ ] walk walk
away walk away and I understand that
you're not understanding these red flags
cuz you're 24 years old and your dick is
just running the situation other don't
read the rest as he was I mean I want to
hook up with her but I don't really want
a relationship with the 40 year old
broad with the kid we haven't done
anything yet great great time to ask for
help he said but we're going on a date
this Friday as always [ __ ] your own face
and go Bruins yeah dude
I would walk away I wouldn't even go out
with her I wouldn't even go out with her
I would just walk the [ __ ] away because
I'll tell you right now you know she
wants a relationship alright so right
now if you're just gonna [ __ ] her and
then leave that's kind of bad doesn't be
bad karma not that I really believe him
why I kind of do but I don't I don't
know I actually believe you have to
believe in karma for it to come back and
get you because in reality bad shits
gonna happen anyways any hope that's my
Karma
I would yeah I'd either break that date
off or I would tell her beforehand which
is gonna piss her off and then she's not
gonna bang anyways the time to have had
that conversation in the future sir when
you meet an older woman and they know
what the [ __ ] they want
when they hitting on you whatever you
just just let them know you're single
and you're just trying to have fun
you're not trying to get into a
relationship and you just throw that out
there and if they still jump on the
[ __ ] hook pull them into the boat if
not you got a catch and release catch
and release
alright is that it is that the podcast
for this week god dammit did I do enough
friggin time alright I have a lot of
people to thank this week I want to
thank all you guys for listening I want
to thank everybody who's going to be
coming out to the podcast festival in
Phoenix
I want to thank Primus for putting on a
[ __ ] amazing show we got to go
backstage me and Dean and meet him for a
second thing with the nicest coolest
[ __ ] people ever everybody around him
everybody was awesome
jimmie vaughan another great guy
another amazing show thank you for the
amazing show thank you to him and his
wife for being so cool and being such
great just great people everybody at f1
I just I just had a [ __ ] great time
got a gif shot thank you to will Buxton
for throwing in the Rikki Rockett for
the Daniel Ricciardo intro and that's it
I'll check in on you guys on Thursday
what about the [ __ ] Rams the Los
Angeles Rams what would happen if they
actually sold out that giant [ __ ]
Stadium for a regular-season game come
on Los Angeles they're from there they
left once you got your old girlfriend
back treat her right treat her right
all right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll check in on you on Thursday